hi everyone it's jerry i am on
leadchest.org
hopping into
an hourly super blitz arena
so three minute chests
57 minute tournament
a little room for air
if you're going to win these events
that's been my
experience so far
i can't really afford
more than one loss
kind of cutting it close with a single
loss
in these 57 minute events
okay so it's
tense right out of the gate
i don't want to commit just yet
um i'll go
i'll go now and then go for b4
that was the plan
i think normally the bishop might go to
b6 to still look forward to this advance
but uh
he may be
subjected to a c5 push i'll go here
still going to hold off on deploying my
bishop for the moment
maybe now is a good time to pull the
trigger on the capture i have a new
option on v5
see how they recapture for starters
okay so no isolated queen pawn
think i like this idea
i am generating a threat
and instead of castles i think i'm gonna
go here
this is protected otherwise there could
be some tricks
okay
so
i guess
maybe knight to e4
sort of drawn to this 94 move
it's a little scary
because i'm restricted with my queen and
my knight is hanging
hopefully i'm not missing some trick
some sacrifice here i have this covered
okay
maybe i have to withdraw my knight okay
maybe we insert this first
because if queen takes i have knight d6
so if they pull the bishop off then
there's no trick here
yeah there's some inconvenience there so
maybe
i guess knight d6
so we're going to have just a minor
minor piece and balance i'm expecting
the check oh really
well i don't have any choice there
that was clever
did not see that one coming
huh
wow all right
sneaky
um i guess i have to
take the bishop
wow
underdeveloped
wow okay so
i don't have any choice
bonus opponent keeps forcing uh
forcing my hand
okay i guess we're going to try
to get to this back rank
my pawns can easily fall doubled and
isolated
insert the check
and go after a pawn
maybe knight c6
okay so i'm defending here and cutting
the rook
off if they go here i could take
rook takes push and i'm going to be able
to promote
and they miss that one
so minor peace and bounds coming up
down on the clock oh no they have knight
here but i have rook here
okay i think this is
this is making the conversion easier
because now my pawn lives
and i guess we just improved my king
yeah that should be the winning way
scoop up this pawn on the way
i don't even know if i have to
sidestep
a skewer
king c4 rook c2
i'll say that's that's okay i get the
queen and
i am up a rook
i'd be up uh
i'm already up a pawn i should be saying
yeah nothing nothing exciting is going
to happen here
get this guy
it should be made soon queen here rook
here
should do the trick
okay
multiple moves there caught me off guard
well calculated with that uh queen seats
free move bishop on b5 in the end
hanging
okay
first one
in the books
okay
um i'll go with this again
i've been playing this
c3
against the english for a bit
all right
slow development
a tame start i should say
okay so quick strike here
queen d7
i could play i could play knight a5 um
i feel like i'm in time to get these
moves in
so i'll go for that
be different if white was a little
quicker to get this knight in here so i
have to be concerned about a bishop b5
following up
hopefully that's not going to hurt me
also in time to stop this coordination
rick ca
i'm prepared to knock out the knight if
it goes to f3 yeah i think it's
important i do this
knight here is going to be way way way
too much
and
bishop am i okay with the dark square
bishop exchange
um
i'm going to save for now no
i want to watch out for this maneuver
into c5
i guess they're going queen side
all right bishop h6 i have this or
knight here
let's get this rook here so now there's
this new option to defend against g7
a bit risky this idea keeping the king
in the center but i'm not quite sure how
to get at the king
knight b4 can be a move i can also
consider g6
i think i'm cool with g6
now let's go with g6
h4 h5 maybe nearby
trying to stir up some trouble in the
center
if i could get this break in i think i'd
like that so maybe maybe we shoot for
this
e5
knight recaptures bishop b5 let's see
let's let's go for this one
i'm going with the what the general rule
says here king's still in the center
it's uncastled so let's try and get at
him
may have to give up this pawn
i'd like to get this one in so i could
take the light square bishop but also
there's this double attacker
queen h3 looks pretty appealing
let's go for this one
here and here
so
oh really they resigned
i guess it's going to be tough to defend
but
i don't know i was looking at maybe
i don't know yeah maybe it is
too much but i was still looking
i was expecting my opponent to play out
at least a couple more moves
all right
just over 200 in there
all right
arrow navigation
let's go with the sicilian in this one
and a d6
see what we get
knightorf
bishop e3 okay
where's that knight going b3 alrighty
begin with
bishop e6
stop sonny bishop c4
and i'm gonna try this h5 move
put a halt to the the quick g4
put this guy right here for right now
no other option
going king side that's different okay
let's keep these guys connected
i want to take some care over d5
paving the way for rook c8
yeah let's go rook c8
i don't know if i want a castle i don't
think it's
straight away do i want to play with b5
go with queen here first
b5 i think i run into this a4 and this
the structure starts to collapse
um
can i play with d5 right now
gonna be some tricks
um maybe
maybe this one
let's try this a knight into the c4
square
can be disruptive okay so they're
prepared to take out my knight as soon
as he goes to c4
uh let's still
go there
bishop here and knight here can be
controlling a lot of squares my queen
might be short
on squares shortly
i have three on
the d5 advance i'm supporting it
three times
so knight a5 queen here bishop b6 okay
going in this way
i feel like i want to play king f8
instead of castles yeah let's go king f8
castling bishop h6 like in the
the game just a bit ago
oh right
they're they're ready to work on this
square okay let's go for this
i'm changing my mind now that there's no
light square bishop there
okay
how do i make forward progress
i'm not sure
maybe i still play with
yeah i don't know
way down on the clock
okay let's go with this one maybe i'm
i'm threatening to take the knight
bishop c4 can maybe be a move i don't
know
tough to say
bishop pawn
got the
bishop i'm expecting night in here
fortunately this this is not such a
great piece they have this big square
oh my goodness i almost blundered my
queen
uh yeah
okay let's go here
my structure is going to be pretty
messed up
so i have this one an important
inbetweener
i think okay so there's queen f2 maybe
down upon
maybe
maybe i get c2
gotta regain they get this i get that no
i don't even get this one
all right
not looking good
i think i have to try
to hold this
this position being down upon two pawns
they're not going after this straight
away
trouble city
we would take a pawn
yeah rook i should have played back
eight seconds
that's surprising
no time though
hmm
uh
i had to guess
too little time
oh where did i exhaust all my
time in that one
hmm
what am i regretting in that game my
initial thought after this one that loss
is
my knight drifting into c4
they got rid of their light square they
took out my knight and i had one last
minor piece around to secure my d5
square
hmm
maybe
maybe my thought about
b5 and uh what kept me from the b5 the
a4 strike
maybe i should still be going with b5
there
enforcing
forcing that knight to jump into d5
earlier
okay
i
thought i was liking my position there
it's it's a bit unusual to see queen
side or king side castles normally it's
queen side
like that that'll be the consistent
follow-up
when uh
when you play f3
preparing g4 but that didn't happen
okay i'm getting some useful tempos in
here
against their queen a5 bishop e3 now
they're in a pin
looking at knight c4 now
okay
to take or jump here
i think i like the idea of taking
and then not welcoming a knight exchange
i'm going to go here
this is the weakest square c6
so
let's go here watching over c4 with this
move as well this is something that
white could have played in the previous
game against me when i was
angling for this square alright so
knight c6
um let me let me go here
this could have maybe been a disrupting
move
all right so that's covered
let's go here this is a little more
sensitive now
maybe i take here
i'm really looking more more so towards
rook e to c1 though
all right
um
that
should be winning at least the exchange
for me
uh maybe maybe i'm winning the full rook
okay because i could take here and then
play knight b6 discovered attack against
the queen
i think their best chance is to get the
two minor pieces for the queen now
pretty sure playing
queen to b4
it's the only safe square if you want to
play with the queen so now i'm getting a
full rook
is there something better i don't think
so
the idea to take here
okay
but i could rescue
my night now
take
here they got a couple pawns
but that can't be enough
all right how do we do this
rook versus two pawns and bounds
queen takes here
i'm just looking for a
a simple way to coordinate
uh i'm going to begin with this one
because uh this is a great square for my
bishop
let's neutralize that diagonal bishop on
c3 and we'll go from there
that's the plan
check
i'll go
here i guess
queen f4 of king h2
so i'll go here
this pawn is pinned i don't want to
look to extend the scope of this bishop
though
take twice for me so
rook takes here there's bishop b5
but i could take with the queen
nothing fancy going on with sacrifices
on f3
i just want a queen exchange now
fish up there
offer a queen exchange
52 apiece
and i'm just gonna have the queen stick
around
on g3
okay
let's start with this one they've
they've opened up this diagonal
yeah they missed that i'm on this one
all right so
that fancy night move to the edge there
wasn't quite working out for them
i was gifted too many tempe i believe on
the queen side
and that eventually translated into
something
material
space
first space then material
all right sophie and ketoing
i think that's a little
unusual
um
i guess we'll go here
this knight's going to want to move at
some point so let me
watch over this e5 square i think that's
a nice
jumping point
i guess we'll begin by getting to the
open file
i'll probably want to have my pawn on c6
or
actually why c6 they're not uh
i could play with c4
let's go with c4
or excuse me c5 c5 knight c6
yeah
okay so my plan here is to replenish the
knight
it's going to be my
key defender of this
d5 point
not i'm not going to bring the queen out
the knight is definitely the one that
belongs there i need to move the knight
for my queen side to
be free
where does my queen belong
this seems natural
bishop i'm not sure
bishop g4 h3 is probably useful
maybe i go more conservative bishop on
d7 i have this long-term asset
you know let's start with this one
i really get yeah no i don't think i'm
really gaining a whole
lot so
i guess we're soon gonna have all rooks
off here
i'm gonna have to try and uh put these
guys to work
just a controlling move v6 control the
knight
looking at the f5 square i guess
not sure what that uh that knight is up
to
i'm just getting off of that diagonal
yeah
in case they try that one
that was my plan so they've weakened
some dark squares this this square right
here
aren't they kind of asking for trouble
um
i'm gonna go here
the idea being that if they eventually
capture on this square in the end
they're going to have this this pawn
which is a bit weak
yeah this knight is definitely a
on a good square but currently under
control because of this guy
no no fancy sacrifices so things should
be
cool on the king side
uh
maybe maybe i should have
yeah let's let's insert this one first
and then this
in the end i have no i was going to say
it's unprotected on this square it's not
quite
my knight's defending my knight's also
stopping any rook to e8 follow up
a rook on this square would be putting
some pressure on the knight
so in the end i'm really looking at this
d3 pawn now that they've
pulled the trigger on d5
it may have been better for white to
maintain the tension
so i could take and follow up with some
check with my queen
i guess i'll initiate the capture
and let's begin with this one i don't
want to insert the check just yet i'm
gonna keep that option open and maybe
work on a pin here
okay that one's not quite working oh
maybe i do have a trick up my sleeve
c4 knight takes then the check i could
take the knight
i'm gonna go for that one
yeah so they ran into this i have two
different checks i guess we'll go with
this one
and queen takes knight it's the
follow-up 38 seconds though
fancy sequence
look at the f2 square next
let's go bishop here
yeah that one
let's give the check
if they're going to recapture let them
recapture and be a bit
backward there
okay maybe maybe knight g4 was moved but
i just want to get my king centralized
at this stage
a pawn for the bishop
is the imbalance
i don't want to see the knight get here
22 seconds
let's stop any knight f4
and maybe knight to b5
and then put my knight on uh one of
these two
yeah time and maneuver
let's flick in this check
now let's let's go here
i could enter with my king
i thought
not
it's getting to this square
a little annoying not the cleanest
approach here
making life difficult okay we finally
get the uh
the night out
that's helpful
all right they're down on time in the
end
got eight fishing for my first four
there's only 29 minutes left
first place 21 this guy has
been going
100 berserk
all right
see who we get
what would a four put me at maybe i jump
up to page one with a four
um okay let's try let's mix it up no
sicilian this time
french defense
looking for something simple with this
line
the bad bishops
good bishops bad bishops
this is a poor line that i'm going into
bishop e3 now bishop e3 king a6 i would
need to play
okay
let's go here
i went back home because i want to be
able to make use of this square with the
knight
might be going home with the queen soon
i don't want to see this pawn race down
to a6 that would create a big gap on b5
i could see a knight get in there
um
i think i want to start with this one
be careful clean has pressure on these
two points
okay that's a committal move
i have to under develop yet again
but long term
maybe this is uh this is a problem
remains to be
seen right i need to get castled
and then my knight is lacking squares if
they play h4 i think i have to play h5 i
can't have my knight constantly harassed
and then maybe maybe in the end it gets
here
this is sharp play
very direct play by my opponent
i almost feel like i i need to
give up a pawn
what's the best way to do that
i'm going to
i feel like allowing this knight to get
to c4
is gonna really hurt me
so i'm pitching upon to hopefully
buy myself time to complete development
so knight or queen takes
bishop c5 maybe a knight on c5
maybe okay so they
seeing that idea and they say
not having any of it
all right so i'm i'm up upon they have a
square let's go back home a lot of back
home moves
bishop here
maybe i should have gone to c7
if pawn takes pawn i think i want to
take with the rook so i have c6 for my
knight
let's get castled
before i get killed
right there
okay let's go here
they're angling for d6
no light square bishop the queen
queen looks pretty good here i don't see
her getting chased away
on the next move at least
in the night not long enough oh wait i
have some trick here
i could play queen g2 right now
like coming up queen g2 and then okay
now now the queen's defended forget
about that but
or maybe i shouldn't forget about that
let me oh no no no knight b6 was a
threat
my bishop was guarding
these two night jumps
still up a pawn
a bit down on the clock
queen right here would be threatening
mate but then i'd flick in h6 if i play
h6 early maybe there's knight takes pawn
knight takes here i have this
and this is still secure but these these
points are certainly sensitive
i'm on this a bunch
i'm on this three times now
do i go here first
i think i want to kick this knight away
okay so now
we take
i guess we take
now let's go here
take here first 38 seconds
uh so now it's tricky
in the end queen takes pawn i have
knight f3
yeah
that's square
in the end i liked what they were doing
though on the queen side
and they resigned
they
yeah that's a good line what they did i
think following up with bishop e3
instead of
capturing my light square bishop bishop
e3 i have to play queen a6
as otherwise queen c6 there's knight d4
i'm losing
so
yeah keeping the tension for another
move at least i think would have been a
wise choice let's go with the king's
indian attack
system
in reply to the cairo
okay an early pinnaroni all right let's
let's i'm not going to go with the fiend
cat i know that this bishop has made
that decision early decision wow
all right so i'm okay with an ending
do i want to take up the bishop let's go
with the bishop keep some pressure here
yeah
all right c3
queen c2
in the end maybe i end up fianchettoing
g3 bishop g2
okay now let's let's try something where
we
try and
try and make this pawn flinch i
guess um
let's see if it flinches
i'm on it three times now maybe a bit
awkward to defend
okay am i not winning out with this pawn
here
i have three on it let's go for it
bishop in the end is hanging
on d4 any knight move strikes at it but
i'm on this i could play bishop here
or bishop here which one's best i need
to defend this
or i could play this one but i don't
know if i want to weaken the dark
squares
um actually i will weaken the dark
squares and say that i like my bishop
too much
on this square
opposite the king it's a home
i have this i have to watch out for this
trick i am possibly in a pin right now
queen takes bishop is a threat
so
let's get out of that
by maybe grabbing a phone
yeah i guess i'll be a little greedy
here
let's grab a pawn
knight d4 i could work around for a move
go back home with the queen and then
challenge it with bishop e3
all right i guess we're going to have
this
bishop is soon going to return to d5 i
guess yeah d5
f7 is sensitive
watch out for the knight moves that are
forward
mostly
so we couldn't end up in an opposite
color bishop position
but i am up two pawns
okay
let's babysit
right here
first this one is too scary
some kind of tricks
against my a1 rook so
also to play this and weaken this
diagonal the c3 square it's a little
concerning
so now we go here challenge black's best
piece
bishop b4 i guess here that's my only
safe square
i do not want this exchange to happen
and this knight is
there's compensation for being down the
couple pawns
so now take the knight queen f3
that looks like a pretty simple and
effective approach
bishop recaptures and stops the entry
point on e2
queen can't go too far she has a
responsibility i'm on that f7 square
this is
something that must be tended to
this rook of leaves
i'd like to be able to expand with a3b4
get my majority rolling on the queen
side
i don't see that happening just yet i
guess we get the flight square in a
light square flight square
let's get that one in i don't want to
see any disrupter
pawn on h4
i'll step up this is useful
they're going to stack the rooks
they may be trying to get rid of all
rooks
hmm
let's begin with this one
maybe hinting at that
let's go here maybe i need to get one
rook off in order to make
life a little easier
let's go like this
let's go with this one
rook b3 it's annoying
maybe bishop d5 i should have played
let's get this in now
my king
needs to do something else
i don't want to weaken this pawn
okay
b4
i got b4 in
the wheels are in motion now pawns are
rolling two connectors
ideally i want them going on dark
squares along the way
let's put this guy right here
watch the clock
let's get rolling
ready to push
yeah this guy can't be stopped now
get to take with check
watch out for stalemates
let's not take that pawn
let's take this one guard that
and then return maybe we could uh
yeah no stalemates they have the king
here
it's hanging on every pawn
everything's coordinated
okay they're out of time
um okay we have they just dropped a pawn
there in the center a little pressure on
d5
uh i got 16
first is
way off
see if we could hang on to page one in
the end 17 minutes remaining
bogo indian land dark square bishop
exchange likely
provoked let's start building now on the
dark squares
to coordinate with my remaining bishop
if i could get an a4 i'm happy
so is this knight
i'm happy
okay knight on c5 this is
normally the side of the board white
will be looking to play on
queen side but i have a huge grip over
it
how to make forward progress let's begin
with this no dark square bishop to take
advantage of these squares
i'm supporting knight h5 no tricks
knight f5
excuse me knight f4
bishop g4 f5 maybe i still go with this
i think this is the way forward though i
have this jumper
also this one
into here knight b3 into d4
um queen here threatens mate and knight
takes h3 this is the one i should be
going with something much more
simple
oh they missed that i'm on g2
okay
the the simple approach the one that's
not looking
multiple moves in advance just
mainly one threats
threat on g2 and h3
and i got 20.
15 and change ricky x
well let's hit d4 head on
okay so they're not playing with this
gambit no gambit
let's stop in any knight b5
and
i saw this played recently i think it
was
um i wonder if it was nihal sarin
um
now i'll go with this one
the usual
bishop out and about
is this gonna run into some problems
all right let's see i guess they're
gonna go with this stuff
maybe i shouldn't have been playing like
this maybe that's why it was this
b5 bishop b7 to avoid those tempos
that was tempe against my bishop
i thought they might con can continually
go after my bishop h4h5
caveman like
okay so i got my break in
and they're breaking as well
hmm
hold my ground
maybe give this queen a
kick all right let's see it's definitely
sharp in the center
i could have considered capturing here
because after this maybe i went on g4
see how it turns out i don't mind seeing
this one so let me revisit
this capture knight takes
maybe we have an ending let me let me
try this one
and then take here
let's see i have this square covered
way down on the clock
again
e5
i might hang on to this pawn if it's not
picked up
i want the queens off
what are they considering maybe knight
takes f6 first
i'm underdeveloped i'm still two away
from castling
okay they're taking like that so
knight takes night
queen takes night
i'll go at night takes night
okay queens are off
knight here
play with the night on still
no
a little too scary
and get to the open file i'm also in a
spot to defend b7 i gotta pick up the
pace
this is at least equal for white we'll
see what these next couple moves look
like
okay
sneaky move
all right hopefully this one isn't gonna
hurt me
that might have been something
it's not i i mean i think it's okay to
put the pawns on dark here
maybe i grabbed that pawn my king is a
little more active
let's go
with this one
i don't want to see rook there
gotta go faster oh man
have a check let's get out of pins
they try and double on the d file i have
a bishop f4 move
um
maybe there's a bishop a5 to kick my
rooks from defending my bishop
this could be a problem
we'll see look here i have the check
bishop here i still have the check
though
okay i need to get out of the pin
i could have played bishop here
that would have been better
let's still go for it with rook here as
the follow-up
how am i making progress here
rook on this square 14 seconds
10 seconds
oh it's a one king and pawn ending
wow
that middle game was way way way too
tense
okay
i might have to try b5 i wasn't i was
referencing nihal sauron playing b5 i
think it was a bullet game i was
watching
might have been him or boris grouchov
two very
solid
um yeah i i think of them primarily as
great positional players
all right let's go for this bishop b5
a4 no matter what
stop bishop g4
i don't know how great this line is but
i like it
e5 i may be close to already
how do i want to do this e5 right now
let's go e5 right now let's try this one
hmm okay
support this pawn
got these guys on good squares
wow
what a decision
okay
that's that's different this move right
here
is aimed at killing
killing what
i i want to get my pawn on c4
now let's go at this one
meeting f5 with g5
now if i could just
actually how do they get the b5 break in
let's go here
i'm close to having a complete lockdown
on this position
um
what if i do something weird looking
like this
all right
um
let me babysit this pawn i guess
they're moving very fast
continue to move fast
how do i how do i make progress here
just it doesn't matter what i do they're
they're moving really fast
they have enough support for that what
am i doing
oh i gotta deal with this maybe it's
okay
wow
rook takes pawn is there of course
they're seeing it
um
okay
oh
what just happened there
oh they didn't take my rook they didn't
have to take my rook what am i doing
ready to resign let's play on
for a move
maybe i get somewhere
still are they giving me that
i could take here
doesn't matter what i do
in autopilot mode i might not even be
losing here
what's going on
bishop f8 rook rook f7
still here
take here and then bishop there
bishop takes i have rook f8
a bunch of checks
bishop here first
crazy
time time time
wow
what a game
let's go back here
yep let's repeat
i want to see any i want to be able to
pre-move everything
four seconds
let's get this bishop from controlling
any squares
get out of the way miners
i just wanted to be the queen
wow
glad i didn't confirm that resignation
space invader ponds
they had me completely beat of course
they just needed a couple
um
just a couple
accurate moves there
being up that material
let's go for a different structure here
um
let's go for h3
um
yeah there's this check there's rook
takes bishop there's also bishop h6
which
they go in for the win of a pawn but it
really isn't such a great idea
so half open file
all right so we're going to get some
exchanges in here so let's chop
and i guess we go bishop f4 but let's
get this one in first i want to
recapture on e1 with the rook maybe
queen b3 was really the way to do it
i don't know
all right let's start with this one
they're under developing
okay so
my knight would want to get here
okay so my bishop doesn't really
want to be there i mean i'm putting
pressure here but i don't know if it's
such an inconvenience my knight on f4
should be pretty good
i could look to exchange bishops i don't
know if i
want to do that it's there though
a rook on this square a knight on this
square it's the mo it's the weakest
square in black's house so
um
yeah let's get here right now
i'm not in a spot to
have my queen
okay um
yeah okay so we're gonna take
and i guess do i play a5 here
make inroads
in that way
i don't know
i think i have to eventually dislodge
this bishop
going for some sacrifice
all right
um let's scare this knight away for
starters
control the knight
f4 i should have gone for first
let's get this break in
here maybe i could target something on
the queen side now with this break
okay
yeah i think in order to make progress i
have to get in f4 maybe they play f4
these light squares are weakened
wait
this one's weak
they've weakened this
if they move it i get h7
winning a pawn
um
my king is secure
it's nice and cozy here e4 is a possible
check with the queen but i have pieces
guarding this
this is covered by my pawn
good coordination here
i guess they were looking for this prep
work f4 even evening out on the clock
now
determine clock is at zeros
what do we get i'm not sure what to
suggest here okay so they're giving up
that pawn
and let's go for some liquidation
i have a passer here with the bishop
pair and an outside passer
well just a password
i like that it's on the uh on the edge
i'll initiate the exchange improve my
king
i should have stopped the night move
let's go here first
could target this pawn
to be aware of uh
opposite colored bishops
don't want that to happen
huh
why am i giving away a pawn like that
i could undermine this knight
okay
um
giving up this pawn
what am i doing
careful about the pre-moves
hang on to that pawn now
yay
it's nice
so tricky
okay
no a wrong color bishop if i took
let's hang on to that down to the wire
no good checks
oh it's mate and a couple
promote with me killer bees
who
they resigned back to tournament land
yeah as mentioned right at the start
can't really afford
more than a loss had one in there
and
yeah tough to even get podium land
finish with 28 406 in there
and there's your page one
let's look at the top 50 who else was
playing
what was my performance in that one
10 games
average opponent 21 16.
that can't still thinking about that
game that i resigned oh i was going to
resign
wow
all right top 50.
there we go
all right let's put a good games all in
there
um as usual
feel free to leave any
feedback to this video in the comment
section below
hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away all right that's all
for now take care bye
you